MIDNIGHT, THE SECRET SERVICE
TURNED OVER ONE TEXT MESSAGE,
THAT IS ONE SINGLE TEXT MESSAGE
RELATING TO THE INQUIRY INTO THE
JANUARY 6 ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL.
ACCORDING TO A LETTER OBTAINED
BY CNN FROM THE HOMELAND
SECURITY INSPECTOR GENERAL TO
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE THE IG
ASKED FOR A MONTH'S WORTH OF
RECORDS FROM 24 SECRET SERVICE
PERSONNEL AND WAS PROVIDED WITH
HOW MANY, ONE.
ONE SINGLE TEXT EXCHANGE ABOUT
JANUARY 6.
THIS COMES AS THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES HAS ASKED THE SECRET
SERVICE TO INVESTIGATE SAYING
THEY ARE AWARE OF THE, QUOTE,
POTENTIAL UNAUTHORIZED DELETION
OF AGENCY TEXT MESSAGES.
GORDON HID DELL IS THE FORMER
ASSISTANT DIRECTORS OF THE
SECRET SERVICE, ALSO PREVIOUSLY
INSPECTOR GENERAL AT THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT AND LABOR DEPARTMENT
JOINS US NOW.
GORDON, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
I JUST WANT TO REMIND OUR
VIEWERS OF THE TIMELINE HERE.
CONGRESS INFORMED THE SECRET
SERVICE IT NEEDED TO PRESERVE
AND PRODUCE DOCUMENTS RELATED TO
JANUARY 6th ON JANUARY 16th,
2021, AND AGAIN ON JANUARY 25th,
2021, FOR FOUR DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES WHO WERE
INVESTIGATING.
THE SECRET SERVICE MIGRATION FOR
WHICH THERE IS SOME BLAME FOR
THE ABSENCE OF THESE TEXT
MESSAGES, DIDN'T START UNTIL THE
27th, AFTER THOSE TWO REQUESTS.
SO IN YOUR EXPERIENCE HOW COULD
YOU EXPLAIN THAT?
>> WELL, JOHN, FIRST OF ALL, I
THINK THE SECRET SERVICE HAS TO
ACT QUICKLY AND RESPONSIVELY TO
AVOID ANY FURTHER IMPRESSION
THAT IT IS NOT FULLY COOPERATING
WITH CONGRESS.
I BELIEVE THEIR FOCUS NOW NEEDS
TO BE ON TRUST, TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IF I'M SPEAKING,
LET'S SAY, AS AN INSPECTOR
GENERAL.
YOU KNOW, THE WAY THE SERVICE
HAS HANDLED THIS SITUATION HAS
CREATED DOUBT.
I THINK THAT THAT DOUBT BEGAN
WHEN THE SECRET SERVICE ALLOWED
ONE OF ITS AGENTS TO SERVE IN A
POLITICAL POSITION IN THE WHITE
HOUSE AND THE DOUBT HAS
CONTINUED UP TO TODAY IN ITS
HANDLING OF THIS CONGRESSIONAL
REQUEST FOR RECORDS.
BUT, YOU KNOW, FIRST OF ALL, WE
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT IS
MISSING HERE AND THE SERVICE
EITHER HAS RECORDS OR THEY
DON'T.
I DO KNOW THAT THE SECRET
SERVICE HAS A PROCESS AND IT'S A
GOOD PROCESS, AT LEAST IN MY
MEMORY, FOR HOW IT HANDLES AND
MAINTAINS ALL RECORDS TO INCLUDE
TEXT MESSAGES.
IF THE SERVICE DOESN'T HAVE
THOSE RECORDS NOW AS THEY'VE
INDICATED, THEN THEY SHOULD
EXPLAIN WHY AND WHETHER THESE
MESSAGES WERE DELETED AND IF
THEY WERE DELETED WAS IT
INTENTIONALLY OR WAS IT BY
ACCIDENT?
SO I JUST -- I THINK THE SERVICE
HAS TO MOVE VERY QUICKLY ON THIS
BECAUSE TIME IS WORKING AGAINST
THEM AND I THINK, YOU KNOW, THEY
ARE AN AGENCY THAT -- THAT'S
ENJOYED THE STATUS OF BEING ONE
OF OUR NATION'S MOST ELITE
ORGANIZATIONS AND I DO -- I
THINK THEY HAVE TO WORK TO
MAINTAIN THAT AND THEY NEED TO
DO IT AS QUICKLY AS THEY CAN.
>> GORDON, BASED ON WHAT YOU
KNOW, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US THIS MORNING -- BASED
ON WHAT YOU KNOW IS THERE ANY
LOGICAL EXPLANATION FOR WHY
THESE MESSAGES, NOT OTHERS
BECAUSE THEY'VE TURNED OVER
OTHER DOCUMENTS RELATED TO
JANUARY 6, BUT THESE TEXT
MESSAGES NOW THEY CAN'T FIND?
>> WELL, KAITLAN, IN MY OPINION
THIS SITUATION IS UNUSUAL.
THE SERVICE, AS I SAID, HAS A
SYSTEM FOR PROTECTING AND
PRESERVING ALL OF ITS RECORDS.
NOW, IT'S THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE SECRET SERVICE LEADERSHIP TO
FOLLOW ITS POLICIES, INCLUDING
ITS PROCESS FOR, YOU KNOW,
PROTECTING TEXT MESSAGES,
PARTICULARLY MESSAGES THAT MIGHT
FALL INTO THE CATEGORY OF
EVIDENCE.
YOU KNOW, THE CIRCUMSTANCES ON
JANUARY 5, JANUARY 6, WERE
SUCH -- AND I'M TALKING ABOUT
INTELLIGENCE INFORMATION AND
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE
INSURRECTION -- THIS SHOULD HAVE
BEEN SUFFICIENT TO CAUSE LEADERS
IN THE SECRET SERVICE TO BE
ESPECIALLY SENSITIVE TO THE NEED
TO PRESERVE AND PROTECT SUCH
RECORDS.
SO I THINK -- I THINK THEY HAVE
A PERCEPTION PROBLEM IF NOT A
REAL PROBLEM AND I DON'T -- I
DON'T THINK -- OR I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER THERE'S ANYTHING
SINISTER HERE.
I HOPE NOT.
BUT I THINK THE SECRET SERVICE
LEADERSHIP IS OBLIGATED TO BE
FORTH COMING AND CLEAR THIS UP
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
>> YOU MADE AN ILLUSION, GORDON,
TO TONY ORNATO WHO IS SOMEONE
WHO WORKED AT THE SECRET SERVICE
AND WAS BROUGHT IN AS A
POLITICAL APPOINTMENT AS DEPUTY
CHIEF OF OPERATIONS FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE AND NOW IS BACK IN
THE SECRET SERVICE.
TALK TO ME ABOUT WHY YOU SEE
THAT AS POTENTIALLY PROBLEMATIC.
>> WELL, JOHN, THE SECRET
SERVICE DOES ITS BEST TO NOT
PERMIT ITSELF TO GET -- BECOME
EMBROILED IN POLITICS.
AND THE REASON IS OBVIOUS,
BECAUSE THEY PROTECT THE
PRESIDENTS AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT AND TO BE EMBROILED IN
POLITICS DISTRACTS THEM FROM THE
MAIN FOCUS OF THEIR JOB, WHICH
IS TO PROTECT THE PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT.
SO IN THIS CASE YOU HAD A
SPECIAL AGENT WHO HAPPENED TO BE
ONE OF THE EXECUTIVES, MOVED
OVER TO THE WHITE HOUSE,
OBVIOUSLY AT THE REQUEST OF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, BUT -- AND WE
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE
POSITION OF THE DIRECTOR OF THE
SECRET SERVICE WAS, BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
MOMENTS IN TIME WHEN BELLS,
WHISTLES AND SIRENS GO OFF
BECAUSE THAT'S WHEN THE DIRECTOR
HAS TO SAY, NO WAY.
THIS DOESN'T WORK T WORKS
AGAINST US, IT WORKS AGAINST
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WAS
DONE, BUT THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
TIMES WHEN THE DIRECTOR HAS TO
STAND FIRM, MAYBE HE DID, BUT IF
HE DID IT DIDN'T WORK.
NOW YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
THE PRESIDENT WALKS FROM THE
OVAL OFFICE ACROSS LAFAYETTE
SQUARE OVER TO THE CHURCH.
FROM WHAT I HAVE READ AND
UNDERSTAND, THIS AGENT WAS
INVOLVED IN HELPING TO PLAN THAT
AND IN ESCORTING THE PRESIDENT
OVER THERE.
THE WAY THIS ENDS UP, YOU CREATE
A LOT OF PROBLEMS FOR THE SECRET
SERVICE APPEARANCES AND SO ON.
SO POLITICS YOU WANT TO KEEP OUT
OF IT.
>> GORDON HEDDELL, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
WE HAVE A MUCH BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF EVERYTHING
THAT'S GOING ON HERE.
JUST TO BE CLEAR, TONY ORNATO
KEY IN CASSIDY HUTCHINSON'S
TESTIMONY BECAUSE ORNATO IS WHO
SHE SAYS TOLD HIM ABOUT EVENTS
THAT HAPPENED IN THE PRESIDENT'S
VEHICLE THAT DAY.
>> SOMETHING THAT THEY'VE LATER
TRIED TO DISPUTE BUT OF COURSE
SHE'S TESTIFIED AND THAT'S WHY
PEOPLE HAVE RAISED QUESTIONS.
IF SHE'S TESTIFYING AND YOU'RE
DISPUTING IT, THAT -- DISPUTING
THAT SHOULD BE IN TESTIMONY AS
WELL.
I WANT TO BRING IN OUR JEFFREY
TOOBIN TO DISCUSS THIS.
JEFFREY, WE WERE JUST GETTING
THIS IN AGAIN.
IT'S SAYING THE SECRET SERVICE
WAS ONLY ABLE TO PROVIDE A
SINGLE TEXT EXCHANGE TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WHO HAD
REQUESTED A MONTH'S WORTH OF
RECORDS FOR 24 SECRET SERVICE
PERSONNEL ACCORDING TO A LETTER
THE JANUARY SIX COMMITTEE
OBTAINED BY CNN.
HELLO, JEFFREY, ANY CAUSAL
EXPLANATION FOR THIS, DO YOU
THINK?
THIS IS BASED ON OUR COLLEAGUE,
JAMIE GANGEL'S REPORTING.
THIS IS PATHETIC.
THIS IS JUST UNBELIEVABLE THAT
SOMETHING SO IMPORTANT AND SO
OBVIOUSLY IMPORTANT EVEN AT THE
TIME.
THIS ISN'T LIKE THE SECRET
SERVICE WAS TOLD MONTHS LATER
AND GO BACK AND GOT IF THEY HAD
BEEN SEEM SIGNIFICANT AT THIS
TIME.
EVERYBODY KNEW JANUARY SIX WAS
AN ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT.
ACCORDING TO JAMIE'S REPORTING
THE SECRET SERVICE WAS TOLD, ON
JANUARY 16TH, JUST TEN DAYS
LATER TO PRESERVE ALL THE EMAIL
AND TEXT TRAFFIC.
AND THEY DIDN'T.
AND WHAT HAPPENED.
HOW COULD THIS POSSIBLE HAPPEN?
AND WHO IS RESPONSIBLE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY WEAR ALL THESE TEXT?
THESE QUESTIONS CRY OUT FOR
ANSWERS.
>> HOW CAN THIS BE IS THE
QUESTION.
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THE
AGENCY OF THE SECRET SERVICE
AND WHAT THEY DO.
>> HOW CAN THIS BE?
THAT IS OBVIOUSLY THE RIGHT
QUESTION.
THERE ARE TWO POSSIBILITIES.
ONE POSSIBILITY IS INCOMPETENCE,
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT I
BELIEVE IS AND GENERALLY THE
EXPLANATION FOR MOST THINGS.
AT LEAST, ACCORDING TO THIS
REPORT, IT'S THEY SEEM TO HAVE
TRUSTED THE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD
THE PHONES TO PRESERVE THINGS.
AS OPPOSED TO DOING IT
CENTRALLY.
WHICH SEEMS DEEPLY IDIOTIC.
BUT THE QUESTION OF WHETHER
THIS WAS ALL A TERRIBLE MISTAKE,
ALTERNATIVELY, WAS THERE SOME
SINISTER ACTIVITY AND THEN
ATTEMPT TO DITCH CORRESPONDENT
SO THEY DIDN'T WANT PEOPLE TO
SEE?
AGAIN, THAT SEEMS UNLIKELY.
BUT SOMETHING WENT TERRIBLY
WRONG HERE.
AND SOMEBODY'S GOT TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT HAPPENED.